michael était l'invité ce soir de tpm p
je comptais faire un forcément un pmp
normal c'était l'invité de l'émission
d'ailleurs viendra nous voir semaine
prochaine pour son spectacle parce qu'on
voulait absolument l'avoir en invité on
est tous fans de lui et c'est une
immense star aujourd'hui michael et
michael j'ai vu tout à l'heure il m'a
dit voilà qu'est ce que je fais je dis
mais quelle moi j'aimerais beaucoup que
tu viennes parce que tu es un artiste
incroyable d'un artiste qui a beaucoup
beaucoup d'émotion et que donne beaucoup
d'émotion public et on sait que tu fait
extrêmement bien johnny et il c'est vrai
qu'il était il vieillit mais est ce que
tu crois voilà ça me gêne un peu
peut-être de faire johnny ce soir il m'a
dit alors je vais le faire dans
l'émotion et je vais chanter diego ce
soir vous jure il nous l'a fait alors
une réflexion exceptionnelle et je vous
en remercie encore une fois laurent
ruquier le producteur de mickaël qui il
lui a dit vraiment que c'était la plus
belle chose qui pouvait faire ce soir il
devait faire vous le dit maître gims ce
soir et d'autres personnes puisque même
toutes ces équipes étaient prévus sur
scène et michael je voudrais te
remercier d'être là ce soir est vraiment
et puis un artiste exceptionnel est
vraiment là je vous dis c'est un moment
que j'attendais depuis depuis le début
depuis depuis cet après midi mickaël
c'est à toi avec toutes les équipes et
tout ton groupe
merci michael
[Applaudissements]
en vo
bon
en
[Musique]
e
en vain
derrière les barreaux
m
pour quel coût mots
qu'il possessif
le
plus à risque des shows
emily loizeau
so veulent se séparer
key
[Musique]
quel est ce pays
frappe la nuit
la loire enfin
nieto
ils s'inquiètent
il est fini
solo
[Musique]
ans
mais
[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
es tu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
michael gregorio michael bay nickel
ok merci merci à tous les musiciens avec
qui sont avec toi qui ont fait un
travail exceptionnel qui ont répété
toute la journée
michael on a longuement discuté tous les
deux sur cette séquence tu devais venir
aujourd'hui en invité finalement tu es
resté en invité parce que je voulais
absolument que tu rêves et je voudrais
vraiment remercier parce que tu as fait
vivre un moment exceptionnel
c'est vraiment
[Applaudissements]